où
ça m'énerve
pourquoi l'avez vous fait il pas au loup
francesca en fait ils sont tombés très
très amoureux au moment où il disait ce
livre ce livre s'appelle lancelot c'est
un livre d moyen-âge qui raconte une
histoire d'amour et un jour il était en
train de lire le livre tous les deux ils
ont réalisé qu'ils étaient en train de
tomber amoureux
pinter et en prince cabillaud à la
princesse pensait quand on regarde parce
que les timides 30e fca et le marié
qu'elle n'a pas le droit de faire un
bisou au frère de son mari
mais quand elle réalise qu'elle est en
train de tomber amoureuse des paulo et
que paulo est en train de tomber
amoureux d'elle mais un petit peu gêné
bah elle rougit
pas très à l'aise
il
c'est pourquoi il a arrêté est-ce que
les princes
16 ans toujours des robes longues au
moyen âge les femmes n'avaient pas le
droit de porter de pantalons henri ii
guen
c'est un peintre romantique et les
peintres romantiques aime beaucoup être
exact avant de faire son tableau il
s'est renseigné pour savoir quel type de
tissu
quel type de robe les avez les
princesses au xiiie siècle alors à la en
tissus damassés
yushu ont repris à son mari il va
bientôt arriver
son mari qui est très laid et très vieux
va bientôt apparaître derrière le rideau
mais henry de kent a préféré cette fois
ci uniquement montrer le baiser qui unit
pas aux lieux francesca comme un couple
tellement mignon est tellement amoureux
qui a pas envie de montrer le mari mais
tous les autres peintres qui ont
représenté paulo francesca l'ont fait
avec le mari qui arrivent et qui veulent
être fou de rage la fin de l'histoire
est très triste est ce que va être
tellement fâché qui va sortir son épée
et valaisans brochet tous les deux pour
les tuer